excess water thunders out of the lava  yata dam in the state of michigan  authorities open the sluice gates it was  either that or risk the dam bursting but  the water is flooding communities  downstream hundreds of people had to be  evacuated a landslide killed dozens of  people at the village of La pintada in  nearby Guerrero stayed at the beginning  of the week the survivors are in  emergency shelters others are still  missing we were surrounded by death  there were so many people kills all you  could smell was bodies and there's no  end in sight to the emergency the  current storms have weakened and moved  north but a third one is gathering